[Music]
Freaks and Geeks we have a lot of young
fans that watch the show and so for them
that's probably a show from a long time
ago it does right that way to me no me
either but it was a show that was on for
less than a year and then became so
iconic I think partly because almost
everybody in that cast has gone on to do
such cool things yeah it's pretty it's
pretty faint well Martin is on Silicon
Valley that's right yeah that's right
and we also have I think we have a cast
photo here but you've got a very oh yeah
a very hung Franco Young James Franco
that's working out huh look I look at
what is Franco he's like the Fonz what
is he doing he's like deal with it cool
yeah you got Jason Segel you got and
then Seth Rogen this is what fooled me
about it I thought he was older but that
show he's young God he was 17 so he had
to have his mom or dad on set with him
yeah he was the only one of the freaks
who was still a minor so he's got the
greatest parents though so it was fun
you get to new you know you knew
everybody's families too so you're
pretty amazing time it's right and so
you were doing that show and then it
ended pretty quickly was that your first
big break like what was it one of the
first gigs that you got well God hear
how all green when I came out here to
get your start in Hollywood I came out
when I was 18 I came up for college and
I remember the one of the first things I
did as I found on those things on the
telephone pole I was like do you want to
be in movies yes I do it's really this
is what George Clooney did not sketchy
yeah yeah I learned and so I pulled this
thing off with the telephone pole and I
called and I became an extra and I think
some kind of like you know a half nudie
kind of movie what'd you just say a
nudie movie a nudie movie is that one of
those new DP yeah my parents are
watching so I got to watch yeah watch I
want to call it but yeah and so we were
slated to become clear to you that oh
this is the this isn't oh it's in like
well I went there very early in the
morning to a deserted part of the LA
County Jail there was no food there was
no heat it was kind of like I think it
was you know non-union
and then they made it a think it was not
Union there was no food no he no film in
the camera
the director was a parakeet it is
something was out so uh what have you
know said I standing there and is making
a friend you know I was talking to
somebody trying to you know if I was
there by myself and and they said if
anybody wants to take off their shirt
they could make an extra I think it was
fifty dollars and your name would be in
the credits so I was like oh my god
everything my grandfather said about
Hollywood is true oh no and then I
looked and the girl next to me was gone
and then I saw her later on with a robe
on and naked in the movie so this movie
came first of all fifty bucks to take
your title Haman well I got thirty five
dollars to be there all day so maybe was
a hundred and fifty dollars but it was I
mean was a lot to me I was in college
sure yeah yeah but it was and not enough
to tip the scale take off my shirt okay
still hasn't yeah you're like you didn't
hit my price yeah I'm a $300 gal banana
should hold all that
so did that movie come out yeah it's a
well the hair okay so then I was doing
scooby-doo and I had an assistant and I
was really you know he's a big friend
probably have like a trailer or a
trailer and I thought it would always be
like like that turns out things change
but uh wait no and then my assistant
said oh my god Linda is that you and
literally it was me passing frame in a
very very short blue top in the back of
this the movies about like girls getting
sold into prostitution in jail so which
one there's like that's a sadly that is
very common thing I've never seen the
whole movie but I'm pretty sure I know
where it's going yeah
[Laughter]
you